I USUALLY JUST SAY, -- IT ALL,
YOU BLIGHT HER.
60 MILLION AMERICANS OF ALL
RACES VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP,
AND ACCORDING TO NBC, EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM IS AN EVIL
PERSON.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM IS A
TOTALLY RACY RACY RACIST.
>> YOU DON'T GET TO SAY FOR
RACIAL EQUALITY IN ALL THESE
GOOD THINGS, I LIKE THE ECONOMIC
VIDEO.
YOU OWN THE BLOOD, BUT NOW, IT
LOOKS INCREASINGLY LIKE A BUNDLE
TRUMP'S -- >> IF YOU ARE
SUPPORTING A PRESIDENT THAT IS
CAGING BROWN BABIES AND YOU ARE
OKAY WITH THAT, AND YOU
OKAY WITH THAT, AND TOU
OKAY WITH THAT, AND THAN YOU ARE
SUPPORTING RACIST QUALITIES.
>> Mark: AND IS -- A TRUMP
VOTERS HAVE TO HAVE TO BE
ANNIHILATED.
>> THESE TRUMP SUPPORTER'S ARE
JUST AS COMPLICIT IN HIS CRUELTY
AS THE MAN HIMSELF.
YOU DON'T COMMUNICATE TO THEM,
YOU BEAT THEM.
THEY ARE NOT OUR MAJORITY OF
THIS COUNTRY.
THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE NOT A MAJORITY OF
THE COUNTRY AND ALL THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT FULL BY THIS NEED TO
COME TOGETHER, GO TO THE POLLS,
DO WHATEVER YOU HAVE TO DO.
YOU DO NOT NEGOTIATE WITH THESE
PEOPLE, YOU DESTROY THEM.
>> YOU DESTROY THEM.
ROBBIE SWAB IS AN ASSOCIATE
EDITOR AND AUTHOR OF
PANIC ATTACK.
YOUNG RADICALS IN THE AGE OF
TRUMP AND HE JOINS US.
IS THIS A SMART MOVE FOR
DEMOCRATS AND LIBERALS TO GO
DOWN THIS PATH?
>> I GUESS WE WILL FIND OUT BUT
I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT THIS IS A
IS SOUND AND WINNING POLITICAL
STRATEGY TO TELL THE EXACT KIND
OF PERSON WE NEED TO BRING BACK
INTO THE DEMOCRATIC FOLD.
RURAL VOTERS, MODERATE VOTERS,
PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T LIKE
HILLARY CLINTON AND MAYBE
WOULDN'T HAVE SUPPORTED A
REPUBLICANS NORMALLY BUT TRUMP
SPOKE TO THEM.
IF PEOPLE IN RUST BELT STATES IN
THE MIDWEST.
PENNSYLVANIA AND MICHIGAN COULD
DECIDE THIS ELECTION BUT THERE'S
NO WAY YOU ARE TELLING THESE
PEOPLE THAT THEY ARE
IRREDEEMABLY RACIST AND THERE IS
NO WAY THEY CAN SOLVE THAT JUST
BY VIRTUE OF BEING WHITE.
BY THE WAY THAT THE POPULAR IDEA
IN ACADEMIA COMING OUT OF THE
VERY PROGRESSIVE, WOKE WEIGHING
OF SOCIOLOGICAL STUDIES, WHICH
IS MAKING ITS WAY INTO THE
BROADER CULTURE.
THEY HAD A FEW MINUTES AND LAST
DEBATE WHERE DELIVERY AND THEN
OTHERS HAD TO CHECK ALL THEIR
PRIVILEGES AND EXPLAIN HOW THEY
WOULD LECTURE AND BERATE WHITE
WOMEN AND SO FORTH AND SO ON.
ALL OF THIS IS SO SELF-DEFEATING
AND IT WORRIES ME THAT WE WILL
NEVER HAVE A INTELLIGENT DEBATE
OVER ISSUES AND POLICY WHEN IT'S
JUST THIS NAME-CALLING AND SHAME
THAT TURNS EVERYONE OFF.
IT'S A TERRIBLE IDEA.
>> Mark: IF YOU THINK ABOUT
SOME OF THESE BROKEN DOWN RURAL
COMMUNITIES, THERE IS NO WORTH
AND THEY ARE HOLLOWED OUT BY
HEROIN AND OPIOID ADDICTION, AND
THE STATES WHERE 100,000 FOLKS
COULD TURN THINGS IN 2,020, DO
YOU THINK THE PEOPLE ON MSNBC
SERIOUSLY THINK HE'S A BROKEN
DOWN WHITE COMMUNITIES LIVE
LIVES OF WHITE PRIVILEGE?
RIGHT, EXACTLY.
I WAS COVERING IT ONCE AND A
LIBERAL PROTESTER SAID, WE ARE
NOT TRYING TO CONVINCE THEM
BECAUSE THERE'S NO WAY WE COULD
ATTRACT NEW PEOPLE TO OUR
PHILOSOPHY IS SO WE HAVE TO
SCARE THEM OR INTIMIDATE THEM,
WE DON'T WANT THEM TO FEEL SAFE
LEAVING THEIR HOMES OR GOING OUT
TO RESTAURANTS.
THAT'S THE SENTIMENT AND THE
EXPRESSION.
THERE IS NO MORE BEING HAD IT,